the countdown is on for the arrival of  Peta Murgatroyd and Max mere cough skis  first child things like this needs to be  Dancing with the Stars Pro shared a  pregnancy update with her fans on  Twitter Friday showing off her growing  baby bump in a lace black bra and red  lipstick riding bump watch hashtag baby  Chmerkovskiy will be here in no time  the 30 year old dancer is expecting a  baby boy with fiance max I'll do my part  and and I can't wait and he has been  practicing for his impending fatherhood  starting with diaper changing drills  supposed to be super simple  I saw his butt like right here not bad  for his first attempt at diapering but  the 36 year old dancer hilariously wrote  in the caption hashtag thank God mommy  has this handled